our next script is boy with kite written
by a ranae pal a boy with kite is about
a surly loner who inherits an odd little
boy and must overcome her loathing of
him to uncover the truth about the one
person they both loved in this scene
ten-year-old Ben makes an unwelcome
entrance into 50-something Stella's life
interrupting her time with her Silver
Fox boyfriend
lynnie she lets the boy stay but doesn't
have to like it
interior farmhouse Ben's bedroom dang
despite the bed and closet it's pretty
obvious this is storage the shelving
units are filled with bags sacks and
cans but the room looks clean and the
bed linen fresh Stella opens windows
turns down the bed checks under it for
some reason
muttering the whole time oh well clear
dumb shelves up later I made it ready
best I could they didn't exactly give me
a whole lot of time just said you'd be
coming in here you are Ben puts his bags
down he looks around the room and lands
on Stella she just stares back nothing
left to stay then you got a pee
bathroom's next door he nods okay she
nods we're done here and leaves interior
farmhouse kitchen day Linney nurses a
beer when Stella shows up she's put on a
shirt and jeans and heads straight to
making coffee so the boys family go on
I'm listening I don't know what for
you're the only one talking well you be
that way
hey you got nothing but time she throws
a look at the bottle in his hand you're
gonna make that last till next Sunday
aren't you I can make it last till the
end of days I'm that good
but Stella keeps her mouth shut despite
that threat so you have a brother what
was his name again Gabe so you got a
brother named Gabe it's like Chinese
water torture head I had a brother he
died a month ago that shuts up Lenny
like nothing else still a well held so
so you just lost him I don't know about
that
doesn't seem like you can just lose
someone if you haven't seen him in ten
years but his boys here well that's
because you're looking at the winner of
the little orphan lottery turns out I'm
the only bloody has he's not worm food
ain't that all kinds of [ __ ] up bad as
[ __ ] up as us being together for seven
years and this being the first I heard
you're having a brother Lenny don't I'm
not you are putting his hands up Lenny
surrenders okay okay so I'm gonna go
I'll let you get your stuff settled I'm
plenty settled good it'll give you more
time to get the boys settled in then her
flesh-eating glare slides right off him
what's his name anyway damned if I know
this throws Lenny foot for a full second
but it's Stella so we just kisses her in
heads Oh Oh get his name try starting
with that huh interior farmhouse third
floor hallway Knight fence door cracks
open to reveal him in PJ bottoms and a
t-shirt several sizes too big he heads
down the stairs interior farmhouse
Stella's study night he opens the door
to a room filled with bookcases tables
chairs and desks all overflowing with
books there's a TV set from the 80s
hooked up to a VCR both belong in the
Smiths
but apparently they work as evidenced by
what's playing gays glued to the TV Ben
doesn't see the precarious stack until
he bumps it it sets off an avalanche of
books and stir Stella from her place in
front of the TV she uses the remote to
turn the screen black what and the holy
hell are you doing here Ben rears back
face pale eyes huge wait sit go on sit
she's not just a chair forward with her
foot he has a Tate's but finally takes
an uneasy seat why are you up a shrug he
doesn't know
that's when Stella realizes I figured
you were just quiet but this ain't that
is it what's wrong with you can't you
speak no response
just those watchful eyes so why are you
up
can't get to sleeping got a worm in your
head Ben touches his head looks alarmed
at the thought got a real worm Jesus
Christ I meant a feeling like how I knew
you were gonna be a boy when your father
told me he knocked up your mother she
looks at him really looks and what she
sees does not make her happy
god damn you're everything I knew would
happen he was just too blind or too
stupid to see it well too bad for him
too bad for me too I suppose there's a
bitter taste to her words so she grabs a
random book off of a table shoves it at
him here it'll help you sleep
go on get your ass back to bed Stella
hits play on the remote and the TV
sounds follow Ben out the door interior
farmhouse Ben's bedroom day Ben climbs
into bed with the book on Paul Klee
master of the abstract he flips the
pages and reaches a painting the CAC and
demonic anguish and dark it's Cleese
nightmares transformed into art Ben
shuts the book and then pulls the covers
over his head sequence stars the inside
of
blanket becomes a galaxy of stars within
the sweeping strokes of van gogh's
starry night he reaches up to pluck out
the brightest among them he holds it
tight and closes his eyes
[Applause]